semaine des magouilles mais c'est à dire
la même chose que les mêmes des
cigarettes a déjà fait des magouilles
tron alors là jamais
allée dépêche jamais de la vie non moi
j'ai pas fait de la vérité après vous
avez plein je te rappelle qu'elle avait
dit qu'il a évolué bagnole
c'est une bagnole qui n'ont même plus du
gipa des usa connaît non on a fait des
trucs des conneries qu'on était plus
jeune des couacs est à magouiller
dépêche toi mais quand tu côté dans un
quartier et à des mecs qui vont en chine
il ramène des baskets et tutus rachète
les baskets pour les revendre un peu
plus cher c'est bien mais cherche sa
voie si tu te débrouilles et des
t-shirts à l'époque des tee shirt de
marque mais ya 25 ans et ça c'est pas
des balivernes s est fait quoi j'avoue
un trafic d'ordonnancés mais j'ai jamais
des prix
[Rires]
affichent leur donnons dans quelques
pharmacies vous venez
bombe a
fait c'étaient des produits qui
déclenche une certaine euphorie
c'est tout ce que c'est lambert rien
rien rien de grave n'aurait plus dû
passer j'étais jeune j'étais très jeune
parce que je suis c'est peut-être pour
ça le nez comme ça
non mais ce n'est que ça c'est parti ça
grandit de partout partout pas produit
stimulant et tout ça pendant une courte
période mais très léger tout petit rap
juguler j'ai arrêté vous avez trop
facilement
c'est pas grave dû laisser pour sa
consommation pour la consommation de
jean a aucun trafic c'était que pour moi
et ça marchait du tonnerre on avait
juste bien frapper les gens nus
je pense à mon avis est resté en lui
parce qu'il ya ilahi là il arrive et la
garder un
la castaldi alors moi je revendais vous
avez des petites maquettes de ferrari
burat vous vous rappelez c'était très
bien fait et je faisais quoi que c'est
démodé limitée qui livrent déjà une
fortune je sais ça s'emballe et j'envoie
des 10 francs non plus que c'est
vraiment je vous jure c'est vrai
qu'on a connu et connaît un diplôme du
ballon on a voulu revendre et des
morceaux de à 10000 euros mais il n'y
avait ni les fais quoi moi j'ai acheté
des strings 70 centimes à babu et des
rejets d'eau
c'est une belle et bien ça ça d'en
acheter trois
ça m'a coûté si mal mais
c'est génial mathieu de l'enm où non non
mais pas vous demander de vous confesser
quelque chose puis quoi là en fait quand
j'étais plus jeune je faisais collection
de gomme voyez des sur les malades ou
100 web mais voilà et un jour j'ai volé
une gomme bon marché si l'on regarde à
paris non fois j'ai volé une gomme suis
un très bien ça valait 3 francs mariah
carey attend comme
gravelines comme c'est ça que vous lui
dire non c'était sale histoire c'est à
peu près tout le plus fou que j'ai fait
ouais ouais vous cyril petit petits
trafics non non dans votre jeunesse de
blousons nom de blousons de blues ont
une sorte suis clair comme de l'eau de
roche et les bulletins scolaires par les
whiskys trafic de bulletins scolaires
bon c'est un mercedes
non mais c'est vrai non mais attendez
non mais alors il semblerait que je
faisais du trafic de pétain scolaires 50
balles le bulletin ceux qui avaient des
mauvais bulletin au pouvoir qui pourrait
sortir à l'école non après j'ai fait du
faux pas le faire je fais du trafic de
calculatrices en
fait
après les faits le trafic d'organes
en quoi le trafic de quelle terre
entière une calculette non mais
justement une calcul parce qu'avant vous
savez que quand on était en terminale il
y avait des calculatrices le bayer jean
luc azoulay s'est révélé en fait moi ce
que je dis c'est que je je trouvais
parfois des calculatrices
ou sa
position est en fait en fait je veux
enlever tout ce qui amènerait compte
calculatrice et puis la personne liège
est claire dumas quelle connerie je vois
si rhône bah quoi pas si bien dire que
j'en ai peut-être une en stock il faut
jouer l'air turque
est en fait voilà chacun se retrouve
avec la calculatrice de l'autre
cette version est exactement mais après
et j'ai dit franchement je donne tout et
l'association
[Rires]
enfin beaucoup de j'ai tout entendu j'ai
tout vendu oui parce que cet essai des
très longues explications mais avons
beaucoup plus court c'est du vol
je vous le dis j'ai tout vendu j'ai
toujours sûr à tous les jours et j'ai
regretté bien sûr alors j'ai ouvert
voiture à côté un autre truc aussi c'est
que moi je faisais beaucoup de paris
quand j'étais petit allons-y paris
gérard y est à tous je pariais baby foot
au ping pong voilà encore maintenant
quoi maintenant et en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que mon père le pauvre était
médecin moi je suis aux lilas et en fait
je gagnais beaucoup de choses mais un
moment gagné à la base on gagnait des
petits trucs et puis en moins c'est
devenu de plus en plus gros c'est à dire
que à l'époque avait des chaînes hi fi
il y avait eu des voix la déléguée gros
truc malade et il est tout ça à ce qui
est donc et un jour moi j'étais chez moi
j'étais dans vachon il mon père ma mère
ne rentre jamais dans match on voit là
et jamais des moyens bien aimé rentrer
puis c'est passé a mis tout ça est un
jour il ya des parents qui sont venus
sonner à la porte pour dire j'aimerais
bien récupérer
la chaîne diffusera
non mais c'est magnifique alors ya les
bras dans ma chambre est en fait dans ma
chambre si tu es parti
comme dû gagner plein de trucs voilà et
après j'ai dit à ma mère nora temps je
vais gagner je les gagne et je leur en
bas voilà et ma mère un jour elle m'a
défoncé jeu du ronde j'ai dû tout rendre
tout ce que j'avais gagné donc on a tous
les élèves tout ce qui y est écrit et
donc j'ai dû ramener tout ça avec mon
pays en voiture année et chaque brûle
tous les trucs voilà vous l'avez pas
j'avais gagné qui avait pas volés
j'avais gagné au baby foot au ping pong
le aux unités des jeux de conneries au
plus près du mur
ah oui mais bon j'ai toujours eu ça a
été un des beaux jours les ponts ne le
sait pas la bonne histoire à mon avis
est r
verra ça sur le téléphone parce que le
côté j'ai fait un pari j'ai gagné
honnêtement et gérant du oui non si vous
l'avez gagné honnêtement oui mais
kossoko taton p1 la chaîne hi fi du
félon elle est partie chez nous à ce
que le mec il débranché la ceni films
ramenés à la maison bah oui je te le
dirai et comme ma mère est très dark arn
messieurs nous
colle à écouter ou les unissent bon
maintenant tout ça c'est fini c'est
derrière moi et j'ai tout rendu un
courant du je suis allé moi même livré
tous les trucs mais bon ce que ma mère
elle m'a mis une claque